I think the only thing that matters in
the world is who's the best at gardening
attention the end there's no other
currency it's how the whole world's
always worked Mr Beast couldn't be a
threat to Hershey's Logan Paul couldn't
be a threat to Gatorade the influencer
that I'm most worried about for you in
the next 5 years couldn't be a threat to
you because they didn't have enough
scale to compete with you you didn't
have enough scale to compete with PNG
and Unilever at that level now a single
human can screw you all up because she
can reach everyone for nothing zero she
doesn't have to run commercials and she
doesn't need the retailer she doesn't
need Walmart Walmart is taking your
money to give to people like her to
seduse her to come into the store cuz
they need her shit's changed attention
is the number one
asset what changes do you see on the
horizon for for the way products come to
Market um first of all thank you for
having me uh you know my career really
in essence besides the lemonade stands
and the baseball cards I sold all around
New Jersey growing up in this great
state really started my dad's liquor
store in Springfield New Jersey and in
1996 I launched wine library.com so I
started direct to Consumer e-commerce
wine business in 1996 and so that was on
the back of a single Store retail store
that I had at that point already worked
in for the last seven years I started
working there when I was 14 so and apps
and signage and customer count and
moving this is one of there's a lot of
reasons I say yes to things we're so
grateful for the Sasha relationship I
really love really what's happening in
cpg you know I'm empathetic that people
in cpg may not like it because there is
a lot of change like I mean right off
the top I'm petrified about retail media
like you're already paying enough in
shopp or marketing and slotting fees and
now they want you to run media on their
sites like we're left with no money to
Market right like there's Real Talk
there's a lot going on and the reason I
start here is I don't think everybody I
I don't I'm flattered if anyone knows
who I am but I I I'm setting up for
everyone to know that since 1996 all
I've ever been thinking about is Omni
you know and so everything I built was
from that and this agency is built
really to be an operating system for my
future private Equity Behavior so I'm in
this conversation deep I'm also very
close to Logan Paul and Mr Beast and I
think your biggest competitors are not
the Proctors and the Johnson Johnson's
and L'Oreal's it's going to be
influencers humans are the next Frontier
and I lived that already I started a
direct consumer wine brand called
empathy wines 5 years ago and in 18
months I sold it to Constellation brands
for a nine figure exit like this there's
a lot going on here and so like let's
talk about it right obviously for this
room there's the realities of your
actual day-to-day like and the retailer
has all the leverage at least the big
ones for the eight of you that are going
to those and then for the people you're
managing in this room or partnering with
underneath there's a little less
leverage when it gets fragmented into
specialty stores and things of that
nature there's really only two things
that you know really there's many things
but at the end of the day of selling
stuff there's only two things this
organization's doing it's marketing and
it's selling right and we're losing
leverage on the selling front because
the retailers have too much power and
the big ones have way too much power and
that doesn't even get into the fact that
Amazon is going to continue to take
market share and they're going to take
that first- party data and make
decisions when there's enough critical
mass to private label everybody you
think private label at big box stores
are tough wait to see private label from
Amazon and the future of what's coming
which is you're going to wake up in a
year or two and you're going to see that
meta or Tik Tok bought Target and now
what like what happens when you wake up
in the morning and Facebook bought
Target and now they're requiring you to
spend your marketing money only on
Facebook if you want those slotting so
there is something I actually thought
about writing a book recently called the
channel conflict Wars which is
predicting out what I think is coming
which is we are in direct conflict with
our retailers at scale and we don't have
the leverage which is why I started a
marketing company the only thing in real
life not in the fantasy land that we all
live in when it's in our vested interest
that can allow this brand that is so
iconic and you do have the trends going
in your direction and I do think the
product has incredible permission to win
in the changing landscape of the
consumer however if this company is not
able to effectively market and
brand it will lose no matter how epic
this sales infrastructure that I'm
looking at is because that's just real
life and so you know in cliche talk I'm
so empathetic for the majority of this
room because we we go so hard to make
the selling happen we have such cynicism
to the marketing right they're look at
all this money they're wasting I'd
rather have that you know those dollars
to get a couple more shelf space or this
and that but the problem is we're just
digging our own grave so I think a real
if we're talking real business a big
strategy in general is really
understanding this opening sentence and
even being more supportive in a lot of
ways I tell a lot of sales organizations
you've got to be supportive about what
you're doing in marketing and instead of
being cynical to it or upset that we're
allocating too much to it when I can
make more of it you should realize that
unless we achieve that it's game over
that's real talk so what's going to
change most of it you know Tik Tok is
going to effectively be a retail outlet
they're just going to follow what's
happening in China like it's done it's
already happened T you know the QVC
ification of social media is here in the
next two or three years the farm
majority of this product's demand
creation is going to come from human
beings live on Tik Tok and Instagram or
whatever pops up next like
it's just different and it's really
different and so of course we can
formulate better products and yes we are
much luckier than other products where
the trends are going in our direction to
our product but unless this company is
capable of creating consideration and
demand to give us the leverage with our
retailers it will be tough sledding
they're going to keep taking more money
from
you all right on that note
was like I got to look for another
job little inside joke I like it in all
sincerity please some of the words you
mentioned what we we're talking about
here we have a unique difference from
our key competitors we talk about unever
we talk about Proctor and you're right
maybe they're not the ones to worry
about but what we love about who we are
is we're faster we're more Nimble we're
more creative you're not faster than a
young woman that lives in Atlanta with
29 million followers correct that's true
and that's where that's where it becomes
this idea we've been talking about from
the last day and a half is about
unthinking and thinking differently and
how do we teach these teams because I'm
I'm scared I put a dinosaur on the board
and the guy in the right corner there is
our e-commerce specialist knows
everything and I'm going to sit with him
and just keep learning of course we all
have to be Progressive that way but the
question I was going to ask you is
around how do how do you teach your team
to go next level and think differently
and to be forward by not incentivizing
the short
term another tough thing in the
construct of what we've got here I'm
empathetic to everything that's going on
here but it is the answer to your
question twoyear uh sales broker right
but you know yeah you know what I mean
like again I like am really trying to be
in this room and say I understand I've
been around the block my gray hairs are
coming in you know like I'm a
businessman like I understand to answer
your question the reason my world is
always incentivized in innovating is
because I don't build structures that in
incentivize short-term kpis because when
you're incentivizing short term kpis you
become too oriented on the
transaction and I'm a Salesman so I
understand the energy in this room the
hell like you know you might not even be
you know don't forget I also own and
operate own my own businesses I'm not
publicly traded I'm not trying to sell
them so I am giving a lot of care to 17
years from now I can't ask that of my
employees or of any of you you know how
many people here are retiring within the
next 17 years raise your hand real talk
you know tough for me to say hey I
really need you to give a [__] about the
next 17 years from now tough to ask that
so for us it's easy my religion is also
day trading attention I think the only
thing that of course uh I think the only
thing that matters in the world is who's
the best at gardening
attention the end there's no other
currency wow it's how the whole world's
always worked I was born in the Soviet
Union before I immigrated here and I'm
47 years old so I grew up in Jersey in
the80s very captivated by the Cold War
because that's where I was born but this
is where I was growing up and I was also
a pretty poor student because I was
really a purebred entrepreneur but the
one class I was good at was history and
now I understand why I was interested in
pattern recognition when there's a coup
in a country at the same time the army
or whoever's doing the coup is going to
the Palace to get the god
they're going to the radio station the
newspaper and the TV station to control
the message all of the anxiety and
unrest we all have in our country and in
geopolitics right now is because
communication has changed we've gone
away from the big platforms owning it
hence the governments and now we have
decentralization of
communication Mr Beast couldn't be a
threat to Hershey's Logan Paul couldn't
be a threat to Gatorade you know the
influencer that I'm most worried about
for you in the next five years couldn't
be a threat to you because they didn't
have enough scale to compete with you
you didn't have enough scale to compete
with PNG and you to her at that level
now a single human can screw you all up
because she can reach everyone for
nothing zero she doesn't have to run
commercials right and she doesn't need
the
retailer she doesn't need Walmart
Walmart is taking your money to give to
people people like her to seduce her to
come into the store cuz they need
her shit's changed and I think the
energy I'm trying to bring to this
meeting is we don't have the luxury of
believing we're fast you're
slow I'm coming here with one agenda the
Deep hope that the energy of the
conversation makes you go faster and
makes you go
realer we can't waste money you are not
in a position I know this business well
enough and the competitive set you were
not in the position to waste one penny
on
marketing and so that's what day trading
attention is for me what's the
underpriced influencer what's the
underpriced platform last week Tik Tok
worked like this today it works like
that what creative works there why is
organic social media the most important
thing in business yet nobody's looking
at it because everyone thinks it's an
afterthought and a nice to have when it
is the foundation of the competitors
that are eating up the
ecosystem Sally in Atlanta did start
with a $40 million budget she posted on
Tik Tok and it went viral you need to do
that
that there we go great stuff next one's
me again right yeah yeah and dovetailing
from that it feels like there's this
whole idea of creative Commerce you and
digital and you've got to be really
present to do what you said about the
Tik Tok effect is take advantage of
selling that's right so what's your
thoughts on Creative Commerce and all
that that could mean I I believe
everything's always been the same
Proctor and Gamble let's use them
outspent everybody at the right time on
television to become Proctor and Gamble
do you know that Amazon outspent
everybody everybody on Google AdWords
the first five years which is why it's
Amazon there are moments in time when
there is underpriced attention and the
best practitioners in it I'll use a real
estate comp somebody bought all the
beachfront property in Malibu at some
point it wasn't yesterday but 80 years
ago somebody made the right bet and they
bought four or five acres there and that
worked out 15 20 years later you were on
the Fourth Street away from the beach
paying twice as much as she or he paid
for Beachside 15 years earlier it's just
Arbitrage right some you know slotting
fees like private labels you know
there's some ogs in this room the cpg
retail relationship looked very
different in 1980 than it does today we
had 100 cents on a dollar to do
marketing right and so they took our
money and SL plotting fees and created
competitive products to us and that
hasn't stopped that's accelerating with
all the data they have now right the
data is really clean this is why we have
to build our own DTC capabilities not
support theirs of course we have to
support theirs because we're in trouble
if we don't but we have to milk every
dollar we have to know who the customer
is because they know every customer and
we know very
few right and so you know creative
Commerce is to me like asking like what
do I think about oxygen
that's you know like yes it is essential
to live yeah yeah you know the next
question is a little bit of a gear shift
and I really like what we're talking
about now and I I feel like in some ways
a brand like us we're we're held hostage
to some of those Shopper marketing
programs and and and and slotting fees
where we feel like we we're not big
enough to say no you know uh you're not
yeah and news alert neither are the
biggest companies in the world right
Pepsi and Proctor and craft they're not
big enough either when a retailer
represents 30% of your business you're
in
trouble well just to just to talk about
something else that you know there is a
lot of change out there and and you know
AI right that's what everyone's fearful
of because we all don't understand it
how do you think that's going to
impact creative selling or whatever it's
going to make it more efficient once
people once people start demonizing it
and fearing it I was in actually this is
so incredibly fun for me wait to hear
what I'm about to say I was in New
Jersey in Union New Jersey at a chamber
of commerce event in
1997 that looked pretty similar to the
room I'm in right now and I said we were
talking about this thing that they
wanted me to talk about called the world
wide
web and I gave my Spiel the way I'm
giving it now
and with the same level of conviction
and the same Jersey
mouth and somebody raised her hand and
said Gary but I was explaining like
finding you know this was early web
there's some kids in here like for some
of us that are a little bit over 45 like
the internet was like what is this like
it was like crazy kind of like the way
you may feel about AI now like it's
something but how what and I was talking
about a directory like search like you
know Finding like if you remember for
OG's the internet used to mainly be
referred to as the information Super
Highway it was predominantly known as a
place to go get information and now it's
obviously the foundation of society
anyway I gave my Spiel and a guy raises
his hand and goes this is the stupidest
thing I've ever heard he said Gary if I
I was talking about if you needed to
find a plumber in Jersey he goes if I
need to find a plumber I'm gonna go to
the Yellow
Pages and and I said for now but you
won't and he laughed and most of the
people in the room laughed until they
didn't and so AI were in a different
place CU now we have 25 years of
technology and everyone here who laughed
at the internet who laughed at email who
laughed at the iPhone who laughed at
social media is like kind of
understanding that they're wrong and so
none of you right now are completely
dismissive of AI instead we're now on
the other side of the pillow we're
fearful of it is it going to take my job
are the robots going to kill my kid
like you know we we've turned it into
fear instead of
audacity the answer to the question is
AI is going to do for us what the
tractor did for us when 80% of us in the
world worked on a farm there was a day
when 80% of the human beings on Earth
worked on a farm and then the tractor
was invented and allowed us to do other
things AI is going to allow us to do
other things we are going to be able to
do work that used I can make a deck in
three
minutes oh and I used to cost me
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
employees in three
weeks now the question becomes what
happens to those employees they'll do
other things you know this is what they
said I mean the car was debated heavily
electricity my friends I don't know how
many people like history electricity was
demonized aggressively by humans most
people claimed that it was demons
running through your
house so basically what I'm I just need
even the people that are retiring and
next 17 years all of you will be
affected by AI for the rest of your life
and in great ways like it will do your
taxes for you and you don't have to pay
an accountant the money and it will
actually be right and you'll get your
full tax credits and it'll take two
minutes that's good pretty cool right as
and the way you sit here and say really
is the same way that people said 100
years ago that I can go to Australia
within the day and that used to take a
month the world's Moving Innovation
doesn't stop in our lifetime and AI will
be one of the most profound things that
you ever see in your life and it will
completely change all our lives however
this company at this moment should spend
zero minutes on it maybe a little bit
for internal maybe decks to each other
to be a little faster we need to talk
about the first stop this company needs
to figure out how to be more relevant to
more customers at scale within the money
that it has to become a defense
mechanism to the infrastructure of how
their product is sold marketing is the
only way
out which is like super hardcore because
again I'm Marketing in sales and this is
a sales like I get it but marketing is
the only way
out I believe it's it's
true marke but but but but to the point
of the joke of all this you can waste
all your money in marketing you can't in
sales and that's why we have the
feelings we have but marketing is the
only way
out with with you back do sales and
marketing but you take it from you I'm
the only way out you are follow I want
to follow
her you know so that you know social
media is important and you know
obviously that you know something you've
been preaching to a lot of Brands and
companies and I think that we've leaned
on it heavily because we didn't have
budget so we actually maybe we're a
little further I don't want to back but
what so what are some of the big
mistakes you see companies make with
social media not understanding how much
science is behind it the science behind
the art you know I post my content my
personal posts on LinkedIn are scheduled
to the exact
minute like I will post on LinkedIn at
9:07 a.m because more people will see it
than if I post it at 906 and 908 and
nobody thinks about that stuff wow I
think about the first three seconds I
think about the creative I all I think
about is how the algorithms work to give
me more reach to what I want and then I
layer human psychology and then I layer
my business objectives and then I layer
that Kelsey and Taylor swifter dating
and how can I use that you know pop
culture and so you know I'm playing a
game of ingredients I'm using pop
culture I'm using platform reality I'm
using science I'm using best practices
I'm using human behavior I'm using
business
reality um so the level to again the
hardest thing in the world to do in the
world in marketing and I do it all
is social media
creative and yet it is deemed the
easiest by every organization and what
what I mean by that I mean it's the
thing that most people don't actually
really care about this is where you can
outl flag your competitors your direct
competitors the biggest companies many
that we work with will take more
seriously a 30-second commercial and
spend more money on the
catering of that 302nd commercial and
the t& of that 32nd commercial then
they'll spend on their entire year on
social which is why they're all so
reliant on
influencers because they don't know how
to do it and so my big take is that
people marketers business people
salespeople like ourselves will go to a
dinner table and we will have
conversations about social media if we
do on two fronts one how it's ruining
the country two how it's ruining our
children right so General conversation
amongst people is they will literally
have dinner conversations with gusto on
how powerful this platform is that it's
ruining or how scared you are of it what
it's doing to the politics what it's
doing to politicians what it's doing to
the country what it's doing to your
children you will sit there the whole
time on the on Saturday night with your
best friends or your relatives and then
you'll come in Monday morning and you
look at it as the least most important
thing in your marketing
mix I've literally had CEOs of companies
who I do business with especially when a
lot of stuff was going on 3 or four
years ago in America and they would yell
at me for 10 minutes about how bad
social media was because it's put
democracy on the brink of its knees and
then we would switch over to business
once we were done with our opening
cocktail and letting that person rant
and they would then explain to me how
social media can't sell their product
the way that print can and I was like
let me get this straight
social media is powerful enough to put
democracy on its knees but it can't sell
lipstick get the hell out of
here that's great I'm just going to jump
off script a little bit because you
mentioned one one word in there that is
is what I believe we're about here and I
I get made fun of for my Bronx New York
accent coming out here human yeah
Humanity we we believe in this room our
sales competitiveness is that we have
better people right and I believe that
deep in our heart and that's why they're
here
the key is to understand that Ai and all
this other stuff still needs us to a
degree 100% right it still needs us so
we've got to not be afraid of it and
embrace it and Elevate our game with it
so any other thoughts on that I'm I'm a
full buyer of that like do I believe at
some point the robots can win I do I
don't think we'll see it but like if you
told me in 200 years like robots or like
dinosaurs didn't think they were
finished like you know things happen I
believe in those kind of things I don't
think In Our Lifetime and so that's
exactly right a lot of you in this room
did not move fast or hard enough on the
internet did not move fast and hard
enough on social did not move move F I
mean some of the people here actually
held on to their Blackberry three years
longer than they needed to because you
needed to touch the buttons yeah that's
right so what I would ask is to inspire
this is I agree with you like again a
robot is not going to a specialty retail
store that has 15 units in Ohio and
placing the order it's not coming not
any time in your career so you need to
figure out how to use chat GPT to type
in how would you sell to a this is
literally something you could do with AI
hey chat GPT how would you sell to a
cliche third generation business owner
who owns 40 drugstores in
California like do you understand that
it will spit out stuff and may say one
thing that you may just try on a phone
call being a human and it might
work use the weapon here's how I always
thought about technology it is the
biggest tital wave coming that you've
ever seen and we've got one of two
decisions grab a surfboard and run it
put your head in the sand and
pray and the second one is not a good
outcome and that's what I think about AI
for you find your way to use
it great thanks uh anything else from
you back or a question and answer just
just a quick one because in leaning into
social media and and how you know those
those those influencers have all the
power right now we've had success with
great influencers who have organically
mention us and we and those are fun I
don't want to say they're the only
successes we've had but we haven't been
able to replicate
that I think about this a lot my so I'm
I'm writing a new book about what I'm
talking about this is why I'm so in it
right now it's called day trading
attention and the thesis is what we're
talking about but it's also that we've
never been a time in marketing in the
last 100 years where you can steal it or
you can get
murdered right right think about the
analogy that just happened influencers
is a big one for me that I talk about in
the book it's what you just talked about
you might wake up this morning and like
something Good's going on you're like
what's going on and then you finally
figured out by midday that a single
human made a single video and good
things have happened and you paid
zero then you're all excited you're like
all right let's like milk this and you
go out and try to find other people that
seemingly look like that person right
and you give them money and nothing
happens and there's confusion and the
confusion sits in the day trading of
attention which means every the reason I
use day trading is you know there's two
different ways to invest you invest like
me which is you make a you make
different big bets and you go to sleep
and you know that your grandkids are
going to be happy or unhappy with you or
you day trade and you're making it in
the margins hour by hour and both for
different ways to do it marketing used
to be the other way nine months we're
going to compl you know we're going to
plan the campaign and we're going to
pray that it works out and now it's if
you are not marketing every single day
someone's out flanking you it's hard and
I'm empathetic like I don't by the way I
wish it wasn't like this I wish I was
Don
Draper I wish I was chilling in Midtown
drinking for four hours coming up with a
slogan and you're thrilled with it that
would be a great life and just not the
reality of what we live in you know and
so
I think that um I think that influencers
are something you have to figure out
it's why I bought a publishing company I
actually think advertorial is something
people should be doing more of I don't
know if you know what green screening is
it's when you see people right you've
seen it like I see some people shaking
but for the ones that don't know in Tik
Tok or Instagram you see a person
talking but in the background it's like
a headline I think you should be buying
advertorial you should definitely
connect them to Gallery Media Group
because when you're writing your own oh
got it good thank you oh that's right
I'm sorry that's right
um that's going to work you're literally
writing the headline you want people to
know and then you have a human endorsing
it that's pretty good you know and so
like you know there's a reason the FTC
is starting to get really involved with
influencer marketing like you're going
to start seeing content the year from
now of like big red ad because it's just
you know their concern is do customers
know the answer is no it's so
seemingless the the marketing right it's
not a commercial it's not a print ad
it's like and so there's a lot going on
but influencer is a place you got to
keep hacking at you you becoming the
influencer though is the Holy Grail what
I do for a living right now is trying to
get you to be the in a place where
you're not at the mercy of the
influencer and not at the mercy of the
celebrity and not at the mercy of the
retailer that is my obsession and that's
what needs to be your obsession
otherwise it's going to cost you more
money to do business right and that's
why marketing is it like you just have
to be as great as if you have a dollar
like how do you make it work right you
know a lot of times in this scenario
people like Gary we don't have the I'm
like good news your competitors that are
spending 18 times more than you are
wasting every dollar so if you spend
your dollars properly you can actually
grow that's why Brands grow that's I
don't to explain anybody here you're in
the business like many Brands get big
with less budget they did the right
thing money is not the variable
otherwise there' be no new
brands open it up yeah all right guys
we're going to open up to some questions
uh anybody out there have a few I guess
we should pass
the
voice um when you mentioned talking
about
Ai and you used
a a noun there that I didn't think I'd
hear you say because the majority of
humanity is very fearful of AI yes but
then you used in your sentence you said
use it as a weapon that's right okay how
do you change Humanity's mindset and not
consider it as a weapon and embrace it
so that it is a more positive element
pain people that are ideologically set
in their
ways which is 90% of humanity only
adjust with
pain almost every one of the people that
calls us to do business are in trouble
MH I'm selling the truth the rest of the
marketing world is selling yesterday and
the only time we get a phone call is
when they have a
problem the only time people innovate is
there's a small group that it's in them
and they win and everybody else gets on
board when it starts to
hurt when I was running around saying
that Facebook was going to be enormous
in
2005 I got laughed at you know what I
called it the grandma effect
when I was trying to explain why so I'd
get you know I do my Spiel i' get my
feedback and I'm like do you know what
the grandma effect is and of course they
didn't because I made it up they're like
no I'm like do you know what's happen
this is 2006 Facebook just to give
people context whatever your journey was
with Facebook I said do you know what
Grandma's like I'm and they would say
what I would say they're
grandchildren okay so we agreed I said
do you know where every picture of a
grandchild is going right now for the
people that actually have children that
were just born
Facebook and that's exactly what
happened grandma said I don't need
Facebook until she did your blackberry
was good until people were out flanking
you or doing things on their phone
called the iPhone and were on the
internet and you were like sitting there
saying what's going on
pain like whe here's what's going to
happen with the AI conversation a couple
people here are going to get inspired by
this talk and go on the offense
everybody else is going to think they're
going to do something but they're not
mhm they're going to chill and then when
they feel the effects of it they'll
adjust it's the history of
man
point four years ago we were here the
same group Tic Tac was not part of the
conversation so thinking about your
point as over investing in what's up and
coming is there anything that you have
your eye on that you think is the next
big Frontier so a point of clarity thank
you my point is not to overinvestment
my point is to invest in
today the business world thinks it's
tomorrow that's where all my Delta is
Tik tok's not
tomorrow I think you should spend 60% of
your marketing Budget on Tik Tok today
all of
it like 60% of like the whole thing
maybe
80 Becky you know like and by the way
Becky is amongst every other marketer on
Earth that would think that is that it
wouldn't even cross
one's mind it's not how it works it's
very hard to make that jump my point is
Tik tok's not tomorrow the answer to
your question is I have no idea I don't
predict I'm not Nostradamus I know my
track record I know why people follow me
but I'm just talking about today I'm
just lucky that the world is stuck on
yesterday I didn't know Google AdWords
was going to change my life they came
out I played with it the first day and I
took my dad's liquor store from a three
to a $70 million business business in
four years with no
money you know you know it just I don't
know what I you know the second I saw
Tik Tok it was musically when I saw it
I'm always paying attention you know but
whether it's be real and then I'm like
nah whether it's you know like I'm
watching everything I look at the top
100 apps in the Apple Store every
morning when I wake up to see if
anything's spiking and the way I found
Snapchat and the way I found musically
was it was there before anybody was
reporting on it and after it was there
for 4 weeks I'm like something's here I
download it and now I have so much
pattern recognition and I understand
human behavior naturally and now I've
done it for so long I have a good
feeling often is this sticky or is this
a two week thing but I don't speak about
it even if I mean when I saw Snapchat
I'm like this is it because I knew I
know that high school kids don't want
their parents to know what they're
texting wasn't super
complicated like here's a good value
prop you don't want your mom to take
your phone to see what you've been
talking about so use Snapchat so she
can't pretty easy to understand that was
going to be valuable to kids you know
and so you know I think but I didn't
talk about it for a full
year you know I don't I don't want to
guess because it would undermine my
reputation but I'm in
everything always and so the answer to
the question is it's in the nuances
right now YouTube shorts is very good
and underpriced because YouTube is the
second biggest search engine in the
world and so we can win twice where we
with with Tik Tok we can only win once
we post boom yeah there's some searching
going on youve probably seen headlines
jenz uses Tik Tok to search I get it yes
YouTube is way bigger and so the same
video on YouTube if it does well you
might also get work from that asset for
the rest of the year especially if you
go into how to and things that people
search so we train at Sasha and Vayner
media make the content that you want to
make but on the back end title it for
search even if it's not directly
correlated to the video so that we win
the search game you know those are
things I think about then it's also the
other thing I think about strategically
is media and creative together against a
business result so one of you opens a
new account that's
meaningful and we're being tested for
nine weeks and it really matters I want
to run media and creative in a 5 mile
radius of all 41
doors so getting sales and marketing to
team up more specifically against truth
of business is very passionate part of
this for me as well right you get uhoh
you got a nasty phone call today the
buyer of XYZ says if you don't buck up
you know what do we go to pour money
into Shopper not me I want to not do
that that just gets us further down the
path of our death I want to run ads on
social on a 1 to 2 mile radius of the 29
locations we need to fix so it starts to
become Surgical
all of our media to that point can you
guys hear on this one yeah good go ahead
all of our media to your point goes to
to retail sometimes more more targeted
um you know we don't drive to our D Toc
with social organic you know we don't
really have uh each day we link one of
our posts one of our retailers and try
to give everyone a little love because
we found that that's a real great
selling point when we're our retail
partner saying hey we are driving all
this organic traffic um in addition to
Media to uh your site but if and we
we've started doing these static images
called you know we call them shelfy
shots and we get more engagement on
those organic shelfies than you know
some really some assets that we spend a
lot of time on so I guess I'm I'm trying
to understand is there a better approach
than just picking every day you know
which retailer like a strategy behind it
to make it more impactful post more and
make the more point to your
DTC to our DTC versus the make the more
make more content make more content so
don't replace your content with for the
retailer because that's working for you
in the shortterm vulnerability that you
have but add more content output to your
mix I I have ready for this Gary V me
how many people here
consume somewhat consume some of my
content on the internet don't you don't
it won't hurt my feelings I'm just
getting a sense okay so for the ones
that raised their hand I have 29
fulltime employees on my
content that was all you you know it's
all it's all me on the copy yeah it's
all me if I reply it's always me nobody
acts as me but I have 29 full-time
people that work on the post edit the
strategy the analytics I'm a
human I'm a human being I have 29
full-time people on social media organic
content wow that I pay real money like
it's not
free I don't know what to tell you I
could I could have literally walked in
said that and left and for the most
bright in this room they'd realize the
punchline of the conversation a
human is allocating dramatically more
output than you are as a
company yeah so the answer your question
you need to put out more stuff whether
with Sasha with yourselves I don't
really care and a lot more of it needs
to point to your DTC cuz all I heard
when you're doing stuff for them
is you're funding your
enemy
yeah thank
you first of all nice to meet you as a
fellow 80s Jersey
baby where in Jersey did you grow up uh
Park Ridge I love it North I know it
I did so much direct mail for the first
10 years of my career in New Jersey I
know literally everybody you know how
Jersey is right they're like I'm in
Bergen County I'm like where or I'm in
mammed County I'm like where they're
like oh it's cold snack I'm like I know
Delicious
Orchards one of the things I I've you
know find I've seen the power of um
twitch streamers for myself and I was
wondering you know it's kind of hard to
convince people who don't know who Logan
Paul are don't know some these people
are you know in these spaces do you see
saturation necessarily in the beauty
influencer space and an opportunity as
white space for Palmer or a beauty brand
to you know to really Embrace things and
gaming streamers and people that have
these kinds of influence that might be a
little bit out of our normal box of
thinking yes it's underpriced attention
and it's the exact demo if you look
there so female gaming Gamers and
streamers are an incredibly fascinating
category and they over indexed to the
demographics that I heard on the end
here of a mixed families and like it's
just incredible how many Latin X mixed
like it like it there's just you know
it's one of those things it's they're
over indexing now the problem is the
good ones are compensated in real you
know this if you're in it like if you
tell a bunch of people that don't know
and they're like oh this little girl
who's like playing video games on Twitch
like let's get it how much is she and
they're like and you're like 400,000 for
a week and they're like what this goes
back to people just not knowing what's
happening so this game in day trading
attention is Charlie demilio and Logan
Paul and Emma Chamberlain that ship is
sailed all three people I mentioned I
spoke to when you could get them for a
hundred
bucks you need to be in the business of
emerging talent because you can't afford
real talent and emerging Talent is
remarkable cuz like yourselves on the
human sales team and the product itself
because it's the right one of the fun
things to come to this is do you know
how rare it is to actually have a great
product like you have it easy right like
like you have a competitive advantage on
just the product like you're halfway
home so you know you need to win on a
merging Talent yeah emerging influencer
somebody who has 40,000 followers who
might just be happy for free product I
would use product all day long I would
just ship it everywhere like again back
to another thing I'm building now
currently on my belief on this I'm now
up to seven full-time employees who I
pay very handsomely especially the top
three who are just mapping the 40
million people that follow me and
putting them one by one into a CRM shirt
size shoe size favorite foods like a
database that so bananas cuz that's the
weapon that's the weapon when I decide
to get into another business and I can
click one button and have 47,000 people
that like bananas and I have their
address I can sell my bananas to
them and when I say sell give them the
bananas with the hope that 3% of them
post because that Arbitrage against my
costs will create enough demand for what
I'm trying to
accomplish humans are the next social
media I'll give you one that I would do
at scale with your product I would do a
lot more Live
Events where people can get the product
trial and I would film it because people
will come up to your booth or your
activation and give you endorsements and
then you can chop that up and use it on
social so the content that you're
recording at the event is worth more
than the cost of the entire event it's
almost like the event is free it's
turning an event into a production
facility and it's the best content that
will work on
social so it's 10 times better than a
shelfie so so you put on an event at a
you know right it's a it's a beautyon
yeah yeah but you know to that point if
you filmed every second of beautyon and
left with 912 you know ads social media
posts for the year that made the
BeautyCon investment 10 times better
yeah that's great and then again let's
talk business uhoh we're losing at
Publix in Florida well let's do a pop-up
event in
Florida you know maybe even in their
parking lot I don't know like you know
what I mean like you can get you can do
bubble I'm obsessed with bubble gum and
tape you know this stuff doesn't have to
be fancy you can always be from the
streets of Jersey you
know question uh in this scary phase of
AI that we're in right now are there any
brands that um are leveraging AI in a
smart way that you could share with us
internally a lot of companies are using
it again to make decks like all this
internal the reason no one's doing the
external is all the biggest companies in
the world know that there's huge ug GE
litigation Brewing on copyright and
trademark right if you were Brands know
that they can make a 30-second
commercial right now in AI in 2 seconds
they don't know where it came from and
they don't want the litigation so we
probably have a half a decade worth of
um misunderstanding and Clarity needs
before we get true you know law this
internet 96 to 2001 was scary for me
because we didn't have the internet act
in 2001 the blockchain nfts is scary for
me right now cuz I'm waiting for the
government for clarity AI is going to be
the same so you won't see Brands go too
crazy just yet cuz they won't use it for
Content cuz they don't need a letter
from Disney saying this inspired by
Mickey Mouse you owe us $400
trillion you're
welcome what time is it
it's Julian what the
[__] I got I got to get the hell out of
here I'm so late I got to go thank you
so much you
[Music]